on va parler car kim à la notoriété donc
ici personne ne peut le comprendre
serait ce pour hâter les lieux il s'est
passé quelque chose d'armes a pâli petit
droïde arrêté regardez c'est très
étonnant
aujourd'hui on a on a deux jeunes dans
le public
je ne dis pas que les autres on a géré
le témoin le début tu dois pas le chemin
de la rue salah attia les mains comme la
caméra tournoi n'est pas que vous ne
venez pas me voir après le palais de
corinne masiero alias le capitaine
marleau qui se paie d être reconnu dans
la rue et que ça c'est sait pas elle ça
l'ennuie tout ça elise le sait qui s'est
confié à télé loisirs qui expliquent
elles aussi qu'elle a du mal avec la
notoriété
elle éclaire t cell fils à peu agaçant
et aussi catherine deneuve scarlett
johansson glisse voilà ses complices a
fait patienter jusqu'en argentine on
lave auto que sa mission c'est un peu ça
quand même
mais c'est méchant
s'il vous plaît ses stars sont-elles
vraiment à plaindre
on va regarder magnéto et puis derrière
nous dirait si fidèlement à ce que la
célébrité c'est pas bien tant qu'on n'a
pas connues en fait regarder 75 la
célébrité est elle un cadeau empoisonné
[Musique]
certaines stars sportifs acteurs ou
musiciens se plaignent d'être trop
sollicité
catherine deneuve en a assuré je fais
des tours il ya des rues que je ne
prends pas pour éviter les touristes et
les demandes de seul fils le papa de
diama des trouve que ça va trop loin je
suis gêné par la notoriété de mon fils
et corinne masiero est à deux doigts de
nous en coller une
cela me gave quand on m'appelle
capitaine marc loos puis peuvent flash
moi c'est ma guiraud quant à scarlett
johansson récemment poursuivi par cinq
voitures de curieux elle a carrément
peur de finir comme la princesse diana
il faut que les gens prennent conscience
qu'ils doivent nous laisser tranquille
ça devient fou il faut qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'ils nous font vivre
pauvre d'études store en même temps le
harcèlement du public les demandes de
celle fille ça va souvent avec la
célébrité nan c'est pas un secret d'état
les enfants célébrités qui en passent on
ne pose plus de problème quand il s'agit
d'encaisser les chèques des annonceurs
j'étais trop jeune
je suis trop jeune pour cette
compétition oui vous ne pouvez plus
faire vos courses tranquillement ou
prendre le métro comme monsieur et
madame tout le monde mais rassurez vous
on vous laisse le métro si vous y tenez
alors ces stars qui vivent mal leur
notoriété
est ce qu'on peut vraiment déclenché les
comprendre oui ou non je suis contente
que cammas est partagée est ce qu'on
peut le comprendre ou non alors non
évidemment parce que c'est ton métier
toi donc je mets bon président mais non
non non pas pour pour deux raisons alors
donc ils peuvent se plaindre et des
paparazzi comme moi et des gens dans la
rue dans les deux cas ça arrive très
rarement parce que moi qui suis toujours
derrière eux et par exemple catherine
deneuve elle peut se balader dans la rue
je vous promets les gens vont peut-être
discrètement se retourne etc
il ya peut être une personne qui va lui
demander un selphy les gens sont
relativement discret et quant aux
paparazzi il faut pas non plus exagérer
d'abord quand on fait les photos nous
voit pas donc on les gêne pas à ce
moment là et ça arrive peut-être une
fois une fois tous les ans une fois tous
les deux ans temps en temps une fois
tous les dix ans pour certains et donc
c'est quand même pas dramatique
il faut qu'ils arrêtent de nous faire
croire qu'ils sont harcelés dès qu'ils
sortent de chaleur ne rien dire parce
que je vois là je ne donne pas mon avis
je pense que j'ai détesté après chaque
mois de scruter des paparazzis mois un
mot amour à celle non en fait maintenant
c'est qu'il ya les réseaux sociaux donc
quand on est photographiée par les gens
c'est direct sur instagram sur twitter
donc en fait si relayé par tout le monde
donc on sait très bien où on est et par
exemple on à la plage donc on a une tête
des gueules et ben on la voit partout et
elle reste forcément non mais bon voilà
c'est ça le souci
et puis bah aussi c'est pour les gens
qui nous accompagne par exemple moi
quand je suis avec mon fils et qu'on me
demande une photo au début il comprenait
pas trop basses qui savait pas que je
représentais maman il a compris et des
voix quand on me reconnaît pas parce que
vous vous connais pas tout le temps je
pas non plus des stars il m'a crié maman
c'est miss france reconnaît
qu'effectivement il
et puis et puis on vieillit ce n'est pas
toujours au top et puis parfois on a
envie de sortir juste m
j'ai des courses où favre ça m'est
arrivé qu'une fois mais je faisais des
zelda moi ça s'appelle un énorme truc et
des produits dans certains marchés et
supermarchés et la personne elle te suit
dans tous les rayons père regarde c'est
ça que c'est en fait qu'ils sont maudits
peter bethune quitte si tu fais tu vois
c'est agaçant effet pervers la notoriété
c'est du harcèlement et chaud que c'est
normal que commencent à avoir marre être
signer d'autographes être reconnu ce pas
t'imaginer très sympathique harceler je
pense quand on entend dans une autre
dimension et que catherine deneuve qui
pardon je vais rappeler son âge c'est
une dame qui a 75 ans maintenant c'est
plus un symbole qu'elle en est juste
marre on peut juste un peu nommés en
dessous d'accord c'est un petit peu
justement pour catherine deneuve elle
est quand même gonflé elle prend des
ponts d'or pour apparaître à laisser son
gré et lv les celle ci quand c'est
gratuit
parce que ça peut être aussi la vie la
vie des gens louent tous étaient là tout
le bon il ya toujours un revers de la
médaille est que t'importe pourquoi tu
dis que ça n'a rien à voir
parce que catherine deneuve justement
c'est une comédienne qui vide qui vit de
ça de son talent d'abord et de saboter
ensuite et elle aime pas c'est quand
magali arrive et dit m on fait de photos
bien et lui prend des arts ina comme ça
mais si elle n'a pas elle n'a pas envie
de ça et puis je je je je travaille avec
vous donc vous n'êtes pas de grandes
stars on veut connaître
vous n'êtes pas céline dion numériques
arts et franchement non nécessaires 1 %
de notoriété sur qui lui permet d'avoir
40 coup ça commence ce star mais oui
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui vous
connaissent pas bref mais c'est vrai
qu'on vous connais un peu je reconnais
que pour avoir travaillé avec des vraies
stars oui stéphane bern stéphane
rotenberg
ouais des gens très connus
c'est vrai que 24 heures sur 24 les gens
estime que vous leur appartenait donc il
estime que hâter la tude où tu me dois
je paye pour aller voir des spectacles
site en est à ce niveau là c'est parce
que je je je paye et je te regarde la
télé donc tu me dois une photo donc
c'est un dû renoncer à un du débat sans
fin les hommes parfois on me dit oui
t'es pas le plus sympathique là dessus
non je reconnais que vous êtes très
jeune alors pour le coup voilà vous avez
une réputation d'être un peu odieux
parfois taisez-vous un peu de cela vous
avez réputation d'être un peu odieux
je reconnais pour passer pas mal de
temps avec vous vous dit toujours oui si
oui en souriant et à tous et en étant
gentil ce qui revient à patrick baz
parfois ça peut arriver
c'est le 36e oui quitte heureux dit un
truc qui te re edit c'est vrai la caméra
cachée ou le 36e puis tellement de la
photo et c'est vrai que parfois on envie
sinon si les gens aussi se rendent pas
compte aussi que c'est au début c'était
on prend une photo
maintenant si on peut faire un hasta on
peut le snap et tu en fais un pour ma
mère tu me fais de vidéos tu peux me
faire un répondeur ouais ça lui ces
métiers de leur mode avec kevin sa
message il ya un moment c'est vrai que
tu dis aussi bon ça va ça s'arrête comme
tout le monde mais une phrase de coluche
qui était génial coluche le dimanche
quand on lui demande un autographe
il est arrivé d amd au petit garçon
qu'est ce qu'il veut et on va pas mon
papa est plombier ils travaillent le
dimanche
non non non plus des trucs plus
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais qu'on rappelle encore une
fois cette chose que j'ai dit plusieurs
fois est reconnue n'est pas un accident
le métier c'est être artiste dans ce cas
là et pour avoir la boule à bouger
l'arrière 10 ans j'ai rencontré tous
parmi les plus grands artistes comme les
plus moyens et les plus grands artistes
au monde
on les emmerde jamais parce qu'on croit
que sait jamais où on se dit tiens c'est
le sosie doit on les reconnaît pas mais
je ne suis pas d'accord est ce que tu as
dit sébastien il ya des gens qui se font
emmerder 300 400 fois par jour non à la
lgv je les vois pas je suivais gens
derrière eux je les ai vécus avec des
gens des chanteurs des chanteuses qui
sans arrêt tous les cas fait 4 mètres
sans arrêt ses centrales à cela je
dégaine à roland garros j'ai fait une
fois c'est un pas une photo d'accord
c'est pas une faute c'est leur gardien
que j'étais avec lui je les vois se
promener je vois les gens les
reconnaître et les trois quarts du temps
les gens se contentent de les regarder
de faire ça une fois de temps en temps
par gacm eu déjà un peu agressif qui
m'agace aujourd'hui j'aimerais vraiment
à la vie de la personne qui vous donnait
forcément la phrase la plus touchante
bienveillante pour les stars parce
qu'elle a compris scoreuse que peuvent
vivre les gens myriam callas et mais
rien n'en meurt pas du tout mais froid
non mais c'est trouve ça mais
franchement ça m'énerve trop ce que tu
dit mathieu pourtant tu sais que je
t'aime beaucoup mais si tu montes avec
moi en voiture ce soir tu vas voir ça en
rire mais attends star c'est c'est pas
métier là c'est la célébrité c'est pas
un métier c'est être artiste mais
j'imagine qu'un artiste il a pas envie
d'être écouté par deux personnes sanaa
bah si parce qu'à un moment donné il
sait très bien que quand il va faire ce
métier là il peut éventuellement être
très connu et c'est aussi ça qui
recherchent la télé réalité
et compte en banque sur les réseaux
sociaux et bah tu vas pas sont les
réseaux sociaux voilà un moment donné
quelqu'un de stars qui vont pas sur les
réseaux sociaux l'udc va parler
évidemment des choses intelligentes
parce que tu n'as toujours pas compris
c'est prendre le thé les rites et
aujourd'hui et de tous les petits les
petits chiots 2 2 les petits enfants les
petits dés les petits de deux pupitres
les candidats c'est que c'est que connu
ce n'est pas un objectif c'est une
conséquence non c'est faux ben voilà
c'est faux ce mec est un peu mieux
hasard quand on fait toujours régulée et
d'eau quant à fanny mater télé c'est
quoi ton n'est pas faute on fait pas
médecin on peut pas docteur au tournant
quand on choisit de devenir dès qu'on a
un petit peu de narcissisme qu'on a
envie d'être reconnus d'être exactement
et on aime ça
tout comme les chanteurs tout comme les
acteurs c'est pas des gens discrets par
essence sinon il ferait pas ça d'accord
une fois qu'on a voulu être célèbre et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive justement à
avoir un public etc
on peut pas dire d'un coup ben non moi
je veux plus ça me dérangeait pas vrai
c'est faux parce qu'en fait ça vous
flatte tous effet comme les gens quand
on les prend en photo et qui sont en
couverture de closer ou de gré ou de
voici mes deux publics
ils nous disent toussaint c'est horrible
c'est horrible mais en vrai quand
content de mes propres yeux en photo
quand on veut plus les maîtres
couvertures parce qu'ils l'aiment chaud
de vue qu'on nous demande des photos et
ça ne fera encore plus chez le jour non
vous en demandera pas comprendre et
c'est le moment c'est ce qu'ils veulent
mais les moments catherine robert elle
descend à 9 heures du matin dimanche et
une baguette de pain pas coiffée bamako
mais non pour la fois l ocl fille fait
mal
[Rires]
sondage 4 int et où les stars qui ne
supportent pas la célébrité normal pas
normal bah oui mais les gens ne vivent
pas
[Applaudissements]